J'ai commencé nos recherches en allant au
parc à thème Disney's Animal Kingdom et
nous avons appris tellement de choses
incroyables des incroyables experts des animaux qui étaient
là, c'était en grande partie cette
anecdote intéressante que nous avons dit bien nous allons mettre
de côté et nous '  Je verrai si cela trouve son
chemin dans le film intéresse tout animal
qui peut voir à deux endroits à la fois
obtenir que les animateurs doivent réfléchir à
ce qui fait que cet animal se sent et ressemble
à un animal nous avions notre chef de l'
animation ici nous ne sommes pas un  diss sur oui
et nous avions notre responsable du développement de lick
Michelle Robinson et nous avions Corey
Loftus qui fait la conception des personnages
Je pense que l'une des grandes choses quand
vous êtes réellement autour des animaux est de
prendre ces personnalités et de les amener
dans les éléphants du film  ont une façon très
spécifique de bouger la tête,
voient leur tronc comme des mains, vous verrez que
les girafes et Zootopia courent aussi comme de vraies
girafes, mais sur deux pattes au
début, nous avons pensé que ça
devrait être plusieurs fois  les animaux
mélangent tous du sel et du poivre ou des
guépards conscients qu'ils ont commencé toute une
ligne de motifs de tissus non mais ce n'est en
fait pas comme ça que les animaux sont il y a
beaucoup de groupes mais ils sont en quelque sorte
il y a un tas de girafes ici
et puis voici un  groupe de buffles
ici, ils sont tous mélangés, mais
ils restent en grande partie avec leur
genre de groupes, tout comme votre maison peut le faire